(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
I AM THRILLED AND MILDLY ANNOYED
BY THIS, BECAUSE THIS IS AN IDEA
WE HAD ON THE NERDIST PODCAST
WITH DONALD GLOVER, LIKE, THREE
YEARS AGO.
THE "BACK TO THE FUTURE" MUSICAL
IS IN THE WORKS.
NOW IN OUR VERSION, DONALD WAS
GOING TO PLAY GOLDIE WILSON AND
THE WHOLE MUSICAL WAS FROM THE
POINT OF VIEW OF MAYOR GOLDIE
WILSON.
JUST LIKE ALL THE STUFF.
BUT WHAT WE'RE SURE IS GOING TO
BE A PRETTY DECENT MUSICAL,
LET'S MAKE UP SOME CRAPPY ONES.
SO TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS BAD
BROADWAY.
EXAMPLES WILL BE "BOOK OF
BOREDOM," OR "LEASE" OR "JERSEY
MEN."
I'M GOING TO PUT 60
SECONDS ON THE CLOCK, READY, SET
AND GO... ARDEN.
>> ANNIE GET YOUR (BLEEP).
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: THAT SOUNDS AWFUL.
POINTS.
NICK.
>> ALL THE SMALL THINGS.
A BLINK 182-ISICAL.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
DANA.
>> AN AMERICAN IN PARIS HILTON:
SPERMALOT.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: POINTS, DANA GOULD.
YES, NICK.
>> JEWSIES.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
ARDEN.
>> HOW TO SUCCEED IN METH MAKING
WITHOUT REALLY TRYING.
>> Chris: POINTS.
YES, ARDEN AGAIN.
>> JOSEPH AND THE AMAZING TECHNO
MUSIC K-HOLE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
DANA, YOU HAD ONE.
>> MAMMA MIA FARROW.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
ARDEN.
>> LITTLE SHOP OF HATE CRIMES.
>> WOULD BE AN AWFUL MUSICAL,
YES, POINTS.
NICK.
>> GLENGARRY, GLENN BECK.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: THEY'RE NOT LAUGHING
BECAUSE THEY HATE GLENN BECK.
THAT WAS A (BLEEP) GREAT JOKE.
POINTS.